five very careful real estate is not on
his side rgn wanting to push for that
wall break no titan thor trying to fight
back oh spends the meter again
two one balcony break one ball break on
the side of rgn now he finds himself in
a tight spot here
oh what the hell are g and gets him with
the aneurysm punch is this enough to
kill though i think it will be four also
in the previous masters event he's a
diesel engine he wants to warm up so
maybe that this could be him getting the
timing goes for the mid
oh again another gut punch and then it
switches sides suicides the plants get
gets
countered everything's going so well for
tomorrow right now it's insane
three
optimal options fighting against jewels
right now but jules looks like he's
building up to like six rounds straight
rgn struggling so hard
oh my god finds an electric jewels
making that uh trying to what the hell
are you able to find that sequence the
cameraman oh my god
two following up just touching and
peppering up the legs of rgn rig i know
just creating that space nice these
kempo steps oh oh big sure you gets
punished by a titan thor titan thor
finds the sidewall it kind of flubs up
the combo but he gets the grab and
that's almost it one more hit can he do
it though
titan thor gets the first one go for
that super sized missile ak has other
plans though final seconds of this round
okay 15 seconds left good duck by juice
counter hit down 402 but the sidewall
will save his life ak is put in rage
jewels gotta be super careful here nine
seconds left gets the tackle in almost
gets the full punches also rage drive
rage art what the answer is gonna be and
it's in favor of ak ladies and gentlemen
and ak takes it to a final
[Music]
you